was machen wir jessica and go shopping
sehr
jetzt nicht gebaut direkt vor meiner
haustür steht es unter wanderern
kaufen eigentlich gehe
was wollte gleichzeitig ihr essen
boah da habe ich ganz da gibt's erstmal
ich wollte wissen was dort nicht erstmal
geht so ein
geiler coppola oder bis kritiker wohl am
ende mal hott und welche gardinen will
sondern weil sie morgens fangen
ja da mussten eigentlich ein karateka
traumauto gefunden
ja so
pkw ford ka und fettarm geht drauf ich
würde mir auch bei gott deko doof an die
seite sprich will die wirtschaft meinem
blog sage
lass es einfach ein dicker
[Musik]
eigentlich darf man nicht rauchen die
sache ist allerdings
dass das andere herzlich wenig
ich brauche ein deutschkurs alles was
sie sagen ist auf der anfahrt er wegen
den gardinen und was machen wir es
erstellt in die mensa geben das sind die
einfach 6
[Musik]
einfach acht gerichte für drei leute und
sander holte auch salz den ganzen laden
und sich direkt extra die komplette
servierte nochmal die soviel kleckert
doch nach dem ganzen essen kann ich mir
erstmal nicht benötigen
[Musik]
geburtstag
juni 13.000
erst meine mutter haben die planer die
heißt meine geschwister
alex mal ich
selbst bin eigentlich wollten wir gar
den kauf baker über die beiden fressen
jetzt nur scheiße und zocken bürgerkrieg
hey platz
war ein defekt jetzt müssen wir endlich
mittagsschlaf
[Musik]
bis 23 ich dachte luca stellt sich jetzt
ein sofa zusammen
du hast die maximale anzahl an ich bin
etwa 8000
ganzen herzen wochen lukas schöpfung de
[Musik]
ich denke ich mir aber zittert nicht
trotzdem hoch kamera hin
die texte zusammen dass man nicht
mittelfinger machen kann
damit
habe ich hab's dir gesagt kommt in die
box ab gruppe.com in
wien aussieht und dein leben und liege
sich
heute
gar nix mein humor ist einfach hoechst
classique muss jetzt bis 30 cent haben
wir uns einmal verstecken sich 28
29 30 nämlich vergessen dass ich früher
weltmeister im versteckspiel dings waren
beton
hier fehlen nur noch ein wunder retten
postern oder
auch die gardinen die wir da drei
stunden nicht gekauft hat
warum musste mich die ganze zeit stand
wir sind mittlerweile mit vier stunden
die kehr- und können einfach nicht voran
weil diese pause machen will
[Musik]
sie nennt man lachs ohne haare
ballack
wir waren jetzt einfach vier stunden im
ikea nur einen
mittlerweile war dunkel draußen ist
jetzt gesagt sollte vorstellt
feibra
brauchen jetzt die illegalität
andere
hey leute ich
brauche jetzt einmal wieso blogger hey
leute wir sind jetzt im innenstadt
angekommen und wir gehen jetzt gleich zu
block schotter ein paar schuhe kaufen
heute euch so leute hier sind wie jetzt
bei santos zu hause angekommen und
die hamas könnten
das ist einmal ein pool
den darf aber keiner nutzen und was geht
hier auf den ganzen stockwerken hat also
dass mein schlafzimmer
nach vorne
surprise surprise globetrotter hat die
größe von sandra
deswegen gehen wir jetzt noch in
karstadt leute aber ist alles gut ich
habe ja zeit ich muss ja nicht in fünf
minuten da ich mit meiner familie in
bielefeld seien
dann 30 neue louis vuitton hose gekauft
tillich alter
soeben viele krankheit behinderung
als engel beruflich macht
leben sind sie
gekommen ist er schließt seine tür
und öffnet seinen kampf um höhere ich
komm rein okay
es geht
[Musik]
dann sollte
der plan des heutigen videos war es
eigentlich zu ikea zu fahren und für
sandra gardinen zu kaufen was sagen
natürlich nicht gekauft
richtig deswegen einmal gedacht zeigen
wir euch jetzt wenigstens zum abschluss
konstanz
[Musik]
die ganzen kurze zeit minister mehr
macht
[Musik]